خلف اسوار الحرم الجامعي لبعض الجامعات
الحكوميه في السودان
ساحات تحولت للاحتجاج الذي وصل حد الدعوه
الى الاضراب تعبيرا عن الرفض لزيادات
الكبيره التي طرات على الرسوم الدراسيه
يقول الطلاب ان العام الدراسي للعام 2022
2023 هو الاغلب من حيث الاموال التي تدفع
الى خزائن الجامعات السودانيه القضيه
تاريخيه
حاليا الان نحن في امان ااه بدايه لتاريخ
بتاع تسريع بتاعه تعليم
عشان ينتصر دي حاجه حزينه جدا همم يعني
واثار اللي قدامها سيئه شديد احنا منها
ممكن يكون شايفينها فبصراحه باحب اشكر
الناس اللي واقفه معنا هنا والاهلي واقفين
وصابرين همم الرسوم العاليه جدا وعلى انهم
هم لحد الان وقاطعينه معنا في المقعد عليه
تفوت نسب الزياده في الرسوم الدراسيه في
الجامعات السودانيه وصلت في بعض منها الى
900 في المئه زيادات تعللها اداره
الجامعات بالزياده الكبيره في الخدمات
ومطلوبات العمليه التعليميه احنا بالنسبه
لنا رسوم الخدمات هي
الاشكاليه الكبرى تصنيف الدوله للجامعات
الحكوميه في الكهرباء هي مخطوطه في
الترانكي وبيدفعوها 59 همم على الكيلو واط
فديها في حد ذاتها ارهقت الجامعه ارهاق
شديد ولا يمكن الامور تستقيم
الزيادات الكبيره في رسوم الجامعات مردها
لسياسات الدوله وعجزها عن الايفاء بدعم
العمليه التعليميه في المرحله الجامعيه
هذا بحسب بعض المراقبين وزاره الماليه
تعطي وزاره التعليم العالي جامعه الحكوميه
مجرد دعم ولم تلتزموا ذات الماليه تعويضات
العاملين ولم تلتزم شراء السلع والخدمات
اذا فعلت التنميه ذلك كان يمكن للجامعات
الحكوميه ان تقلل معدلات الرسوم بصوره
كبيره في ظل صعوبات الاقتصاديه التي تواجه
الدوله السودانيه يبدو ان العمليه
التعليميه تواجه تحديا كبيرا حملت الطلاب
عبئا اقتصاديا مرهقا وجعل المؤسسات
التعليميه في السودان غير قادره على
الايفاء بمطلبات العمليه التعليميه بشكل
مثالي محمد عثمان العربي الخرطوم